We have 2 2/3 plus 8 3/4
and I recommend you stop the video
and try to calculate this alone.
Let's solve it together.
There are several ways we can solve the phrase.
I will do it in several different ways.
One way you may see,
is to write the phrase,
just write 2 2/3 plus
plus 8 3/4.
Plus 8 3/4. You can say,
why am I recording it like this?
When you write the number so,
that these are the fractional parts of the mixed numbers,
these are the whole parts of the mixed numbers,
and we can collect them separately.
Before we start collecting the fragments
of the mixed number,
that they have different denominators.
We have 3 and 4,
so it would be good to find a common denominator.
So far we have seen several times,
that when we collect fractions with different denominators,
the best common denominator
is their least common fold.
The smallest total fold of 3 and 4.
What is this number?
Let's see the multiples of 4.
4 is not divisible to 3 without residue.
8 is not divisible to 3 without residue.
12 is divided, in fact 12 is 4 in 3.
Then I can write down the two fragments
with denominator 12.
This will be equal to ...
I'll write it like that.
I can record it as 2
and something on 12.
What will this thing be on 12?
To get 12 out of 3 in the denominator,
multiply by 4,
but I have to multiply by 4 and the numerator.
2 in 4 is 8.
2/3 is equal to 8/12,
and 2 2/3 equals 2 8/12.
We can do the same here.
8 3/4 will be equal to
8 and something on 12.
To get 12 out of 4 in the denominator,
multiply by 3,
but we need to multiply the numerator by 3.
3 in 3 is 9, and now we can collect them.
We can get the numbers. And what do we get?
We have 8/12 plus 9/12.
This will be equal to 17,
17/12.
Maybe you can see that 17/12
is greater than or equal to 1, and we can ...
This is an irregular liver here,
and we can record it
as a mixed number.
Let's make things clear.
17/12, we will record it here.
17/12 is equal to
1 5/12.
How did I know that?
12 is contained at 17 once with residue 5.
17/12 equals 1 5/12.
What I can do is write down part 5/12
in the fractions,
or in the fraction of our numbers,
then regrouping the unit,
put it in the column of the integer.
Now I can collect 1 plus 2,
which is 3, plus 8 is 11.
We get 11 5/12.
11 5/12.
There are other ways to solve the phrase.
We can do that,
from this place here, 2 8/12
and 8 9/12 to turn them
in fraudulent fractions and then collect them.
We can say what is the same as,
let me write it, see,
2 is equal to 24/12 plus 8,
32/12 is obtained.
I can write the upper mixed number
such as 32/12,
which is obviously an irregular liver.
I can write the lower number as, let's see,
8 is how much twelfth?
This will be 96/12 plus 9/12,
105/12.
If what I did seems confusing,
you can watch the videos of the Cannes Academy
to convert mixed numbers
in wrong fractions and vice versa.
But now I can gather these two fractions.
And what will I get?
32/12 plus 105/12, what will it be?
137.
137/12.
If I want to write this as a mixed number,
I can say, well, let's see, 12 is contained in 137
11 times, it means 11.
11 by 12 is 132, then we have a residue of 5.
11/12 is obtained.
You can do it in both ways.
I think this way,
the way we first thought,
it will be a little easier for us,
because you do not have to deal with
with large numbers like 137 and 105 and 32.
We think of much easier numbers.
Let's say 8/12 plus 9/12 is 17/12,
which is equal to 1 5/12,
then collect 1 5/12 with 8,
we will get 11 5/12.